Today, we are excited to introduce our latest advancement in robotic programming:...
...the Helix 900.
Helix 900 is a robotic employee...
...with processing speeds 50 times faster than a computer,...
...which means he can increase office efficiency by 9,000 percent guaranteed.
But, enough talk.
What do you say we turn him on?
Yes!
Alright! Introducing Helix 900.
Hello! I'm Helix 900.
I am programmed to translate any language,...
...read any document in under 1.4 milliseconds...
...and store up to 50 terabytes of data.
Okay, great! Helix 900, everyone!
Thank you.
Thank you, Helix! Does anyone have any questions?
Ask him anything.
You.
Yeah. Helix 900, what is 4,981 times 22,912?
One hundred fourteen million, one hundred twenty-four thousand, six hundred seventy-two.
Wow! That was fast!
This is impressive, right?